[Music]  the patients that we saw were hot to the  touch  they were suffering from heat stroke  heat exhaustion  no signs of water in the vehicle it was  a refrigerated tractor trailer  but there was no  visible working ac unit on that rig  [Laughter]  [Music]  so the plight of migrants seeking refuge  is always a humanitarian crisis but  tonight we are dealing with a horrific  human tragedy  so i would urge you all to think  compassionately and pray for the  deceased  the ailing  the families  and  we hope that those responsible  for  putting these people in such humane  conditions are prosecuted to the fullest  extent of the law  [Music]  you